voilà temps est sec dans les librairies
le nouveau michel houellebecq intitulé
sérotonine tong au palmarès des
meilleurs vendeurs y en avait au moins
une trentaine des clients qui déjà
avaient réservé leur copie avant l'un
qui sortent des gens parlent beaucoup
les gens mon continent par l'ange en vie
puis savoir venez une petite part en
juin
abonné aux polémiques michel houellebecq
est un écrivain français qu'on aime
détester depuis plus de 20 ans d'une
part ces écrits sont parfois qualifiée
de misogyne ou d'homophobe d'autres
parcs
certains le considèrent comme un génie
littéraire il remporte le prix goncourt
en 2010 pour son livre la carte et le
territoire
il a vendu en 2015 huit cent mille
exemplaires dont vélo québec de son
roman soumission une histoire sur
l'islamisation de la france publié par
hasard le même jour que l'attentât
contre charlie hebdo
c'est un phénomène chaque livre est
attendu comme le messie
parce que parce qu'il ya aussi une fois
autour des seuils dans ces retenues
houellebecq raconte l'histoire d'un
agronome dépressif détruit par ses
illusions et ses amours dérisoire
névrosé il est à la recherche du temps
perdu entre deux comprimés
d'antidépresseurs est un nouveau
médicament qu'on lui qu'on lui donne et
qui a des effets secondaires et parmi
ces effets secondaires c'est la perte la
perte la libido et c'est le grand drame
chez ce narrateur donc qui voit sa vie
sexuelle lui échapper le sociologue
mathieu bas-côté à toulouse houellebecq
et il l'a même déjà rencontré
selon lui la deuxième partie de
sérotonine et son long passage sur la
révolte des agriculteurs est l'oeuvre
d'un visionnaire annonce en quelque
sorte le mouvement dit gilet jaune
de ce point de vue où elle beken
l'intuition exceptionnelle de son époque
a manifestement deviner quelques
semaines à l'avant soit ou quelques mois
probablement ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les gilets jaunes et ce
qu'on voit en france encore une fois le
bec l'a pressenti à sa manière de ce
point de vue il ya quelque chose chez
lui une capacité à deviner notre époque
qu'on ne trouve pas chez les meilleurs
sociologue les meilleurs politologue
meilleurs philosophes si redonner un
roman qui dérange il ne fera pas
l'unanimité
je lui donne 7 points 5 sur 10 et nss je
lui donne un bon test pour un bon gros
nous donnerait 9.5 pour mais encore là
mais encore une fois qui suis-je pour
lui donnait 9 x 5 ou 10 ou le dévaluer
c'est plutôt lui qui nous évalue malgré
un premier tirage à 320 milles
exemplaires
quelques jours seulement après sa sortie
sir tonine est déjà en réimpression ici
louis philippe ouimet radio qu'un des
mots rien